a few weeks back you might remember
Disney's new Snow White hit the
headlines for getting rid of seven
dwarfs and replacing them with average
sized magical creatures piers and his
guests at the time weren't happy
behind the scenes pictures from Disney's
live-action remaker Snow White release
this weekend there appears to be a
sizable problem where are the dwarfs
these are rules made for actors of my
stature I can't go out for the Harrison
Ford or the George Clooney rules because
that's not for me right and now it's
taken away
it I don't feel that's right
well now that very same production has
caused controversy after the actress who
plays Snow White said this about Prince
Charming
in an interview Rachel Ziegler saying
the original cartoon came out in 1937
and very evidently so there is a big
focus on her love story with a guy
literally stalking her how weird well we
have a different approach to what a lot
of people will assume is a love story
because we cast a guy in the movie but
it's really not about the love story at
all which is really really wonderful
well there has been inevitable backlash
online fans accusing Disney of inserting
unnecessary feminism into classic fairy
tales joining me now to debate this is
the host of Tommy Lauren as Fearless on
outkick Tommy Lauren hi Tommy I am from
New York the brand marketing consumer
expert and founder and Chief soothsayer
from sooth Ian bear once again great to
see you both uh Atomic I'll give us your
take on this uh Disney just messing with
the classics
yeah they certainly are now listen if
Disney wants to make more woke films
that tank at the box office they are
more than welcome to do that but maybe
think of an original idea maybe not
destroy a classic from my childhood and
put an actress in there that not only
hates the plot in the storyline of the
movie She's in but also seemingly hates
Snow White the character herself I mean
that's one interview clip that you read
the quote from but she's gone on to talk
about this film numerous times how she
once thought Snow White was creepy she
doesn't like the prince she thinks she
should get paid more because she has to
wear that dress you should get paid for
streaming for every hour she has to wear
the dress I mean talk about biting the
hand that feeds you not only are you
being casted in a classic film to remake
it but you don't seemingly like your own
character so she comes off as an
insufferable whiny brat and that's why
people are so annoyed Beyond just them
inserting feminism I think we expect
that at this point but why do you have
to mess with a classic especially with
someone who doesn't even seem to like
her own character okay interesting I
hear your take on her and the interview
she's giving and the type of sort of the
way she's coming across but you say that
you're kind of used to feminism being
inserted into Disney movies now Ian it's
a smart marketing move isn't it
well any moves the smart marketing move
that resonates with the people who are
putting Revenue against your product
look the reality is Disney has been uh
doing very inclusive casting for decades
now go back to the 1980s and that's
really when they turned the corner and
that formula of damsels in distress got
replaced this with these more heroic uh
feminine characters beginning with Ariel
back then but certainly all the Disney
Princesses ever since have really been
triumphant females so it's not a shock
to see Disney pivot from you know 19th
century German Source material right the
something that they believe is going to
resonate with with the audience uh of
course you know people will vote with
their wallets right Tommy 19th century
German Source material can you really
blame Disney for wanting to call a
modern audience gen Z and yanga these
girls they think differently they act
differently they have different
aspirations in life
yeah it's okay to modernize things but
if you have such an issue with the
original fairy tale and the original
storyline maybe instead of remaking it
you just make a different movie I don't
think that's too much to ask for but
furthermore listen you can have female
characters that are empowered that do
great things that are that are heroines
I mean that's fantastic I don't think
anybody has an issue with it but you
don't have to disparage men in the
process you don't have to call Prince
Charming a stalker you don't have to say
that you could just eliminate him from
the whole movie I mean there is a space
where you can have strong females and
strong males it's called the real world
or you know at least some places that
still exists maybe only here in
Nashville Tennessee and others but it's
okay to do both and you don't have to
make men seem emasculated in puny to
make women seem strong and you don't
have to eliminate them all together as
this actress has actually suggested well
okay uh Ian what about the controversy
that this film has received online do
you it's clearly not coming from the
young woman it's marketed in fact it
seems to be coming from a male
demographic
well yeah well I I think it's
interesting that there's been so much
backlash where this is concerned yet not
really the same kind of backlash around
the Barbie movie which has certainly
taken a different point of view you know
most people who grew up with Barbie
dolls when you open that package it
didn't immediately start speaking out
against the patriarchy right yet yet the
Barbie movie we see today takes quite a
feminist stance and a more inclusive
stance than we've generally seen
associated with the character so you
know this is Disney's intellectual
property they can do what they want with
it people are going to choose to spend
their money on it or not it's it's not
really a matter of of moral judgment you
know entertainment and art is is created
to be received and appreciated by an
audience and this is Commercial Art this
isn't to hang in a museum it's going to
succeed or fail on that mirror and the
Barbie movie brought up of course a
really fast grossing billion dollar
movie for a female director beating all
expectations and all that controversy
tell me I want to come back to you
because you made a really good point
there about strong men and strong women
why'd you have to crush one to have the
other and I was thinking about the James
Bond franchise you know there's often
this muted idea that women will suddenly
be stepping in to play Bond we've
obviously got a lot of female characters
in that now do you think that's been to
James Bond's detriment or do you think
it's been a success the way they've
monetized that
I think that the numbers will speak for
themselves on that and again when you
have a franchise that you have created
around a James Bond character who is a
strong male character you don't need to
go and then replace James Bond with a
female you can have other strong females
but what is this process now where it's
like in order to be inclusive you have
to completely destroy story lines
completely destroy franchises I don't
believe in that I don't think that
consumers believe in that either you
know there is a way to modernize things
there's a way to bring in inclusivity
and diversity but you don't have to
completely destroy the concept in order
to do that and that's why you know going
back to the Barbie movie I didn't have
an issue with the Barbie movie because
it's what I expected right I've always
looked at Barbie as a female empowerment
tool I thought it was a women by women
for women didn't see an issue with it
it's when they go and they try to monkey
with other things where it doesn't
belong that it just comes off as
disingenuous and the consumer I don't
think they're going to buy it I don't
think they're going to watch it I don't
think they're gonna like it no they
certainly watch Bobby look Tommy Ian
thanks so much on that